- All right, we have just enough time
for one more great story.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music plays)
- What does it take to be happy?
It is a question all of us
have asked at one point,
and something author Nataly
Kogan has tried to answer.
Her new book is called "The
Awesome Human Project" and in it
she talks about how to
live more meaningful
and happier lives.
We have Nataly on the line right now,
and she watched on NBC Boston.
What's up, Nataly?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Hi everyone! I'm so excited to be here.
- [Kelly] Aw, we're so
excited to have you,
we're so honored to have you.
You have an amazing backstory.
So your family came to
the US as refugees, right?
- [Nataly] We did, I grew up
in the former Soviet Union,
and we came with six suitcases
as refugees when I was 13,
and began my American dream,
in the projects on welfare,
outside of Detroit, and I
didn't speak any English,
we didn't have any money,
very grateful to be here,
and the only thing I knew
how to do was work hard,
so I fell into this trap
of, "I'll be happy when...",
like "I'll be happy
when I work really hard
and save enough money to buy a house,
or, you know, get a really good job,"
and none of that really made me happy,
and instead, I burnt out,
and that's what started my
journey of figuring out,
what does it actually take
to live a happier life?
And I started a company called "Happier",
and "The Awesome Human
Project" is my second book,
and my mission in it is
to help us all find a way
to live happier lives.
(audience clapping)
- I think a lot of
people fall prey to that,
"When I achieve this,
this will make me happy",
"When I do this, this will make me happy."
I feel like a lot of us fall prey to that.
So what are some ways we can
all find deeper happiness?
- Yes, it's such a great point.
So, the process that I
think is the most important
to begin with is the process of gratitude,
and that's what I talk about
in my work and my book.
The thing is, our brain is so focused
on everything that's negative.
It's not 'cause we're negative people,
it's because negativity is,
usually signifies possible danger, right?
So we have to practice
gratitude to remind ourselves
about the small, positive
things in our lives.
So a process that I teach
often is to write down
three things you are
grateful for every morning.
And it's something that
I love to do, and Kelly,
I know your show is
sponsored by Pilot Pens,
and I just have to tell
you, I'm a huge fan,
so I use Pilot Pens in
my gratitude journal
to write down three small things
that I'm grateful for every day.
- [Kelly] I do as well.
A friend told me to do
that like a year ago,
and that's what I do as well.
It's very, it does
change your perspective,
even if you're having
like, a really hard time,
it makes you focus more
towards the positive.
It's really good.
I used to, I'm gonna be honest
with you, I used to be like
(mockingly) "I'm gonna write
in my gratitude journal,
and I'm gonna be happier."
I used to make fun of that.
And now, I'm like one of them, so.
(laughter)
When you can't beat 'em, join 'em.
But I love it, it does work,
I'm telling you it does work.
But thank you so much Nataly,
I'm liking your post right now, okay?
Pick up "The Awesome Human Project"
wherever you get your books from.
We want to spread a little happiness
in our audience right now,
so thanks to our season-long
partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson show,
there is a check for $1000
under someone's chair
in the audience, and I
don't know which one it is,
so look under your chair, who has it?
(drumroll playing)
- You're not even gonna look?
I hope it's you.
(audience laughing)
(drumroll continues)
- [Kelly] It's you!
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Like, I'm talking 'bout,
if somebody tells me I
have $1000 under my seat,
I am ripping my seat
up like it's Christmas,
and y'all were just like,
"Hm, I don't know, maybe it's here"
What's your name, where are you from?
- [Brianne] I'm from
Vancouver, Washington.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love Vancouver!
- [Brianne] Yay!
- Oh beautiful! What's your name?
- My name's Brianne.
- Love that name, it's a strong name!
I don't know if you've looked it up.
- [Brianne] Yes.
- Okay, all right.
Well, thank you so much,
I hope you have so much
fun with your money!
- Yeah, thank you!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [Kelly] Spend it on something fun!
- Yes!
- If you gotta pay a bill,
pay a bill, but spend
some of it on something
fun, just promise me that.